all right Kevin so here's the big news
today Ubisoft announced a new Assassin's
Creed game in addition to unity unity is
already happening we know about that
game
this one's called rogue have you heard
about it I have heard about it very
exciting right it's the old gen
Assassin's Creed last weekend right
prefer to call it last yes okay so yeah
so but PlayStation 3 Xbox 360 this is
the Assassin's Creed that's coming and
we discovered who the new hero is a hero
in quotation marks he's actually a
Templar this time his name is Shay
Patrick Cormac yes he's Irish yes he has
Daniel Dwyers accent he has that which
is just an Irish accent there's more
than just one person with an Irish
accent of damage know how many times I
have to tell you this anyways he's he's
an assassin hunter he's a Templar this
whole trailer it I mean it's not a
gameplay trailer it's definitely like a
mood piece but he's slowly walking
through the fire and then he just
straight-up
executes an assassin on the ice I feel
like he's not quite the the lovable
rogue that Edward Kenway was but we do
know some other stuff beyond just what's
what's there in the trailer we know of
course his name but we also know when
the game is gonna be taking place and
about where it's going to be taking
place it's gonna happen during the Seven
Years War although we best know it in
the United States as the French and
Indian War at least that's what the
North American theater was called is the
French and Indian War so it would be
really interesting to see how that plays
out because it takes place sort of in
between Assassin's Creed 4 and
Assassin's Creed 3 in turn in terms of
like the timeline because this will be
the mid mid 18th century yeah and so
it's kinda you know it's that return to
to North America so you get to hang out
in the Appalachian River Valley I think
it's one of the areas
yeah they mentioned the the North
Atlantic which is where we see those ice
floes there and I think a few other
areas as well so it kind of it's
bringing back that geographical
diversity of older games instead of just
like it's Paris yeah and my
understanding is it's gonna have ships
back he will but you know clearly be
sailing the seas which I'm glad I
because it would have seen
such a shame to just see that kind of
gameplay come to an end
with Assassin's Creed 4 so it's kind of
good to see that and I'm glad twice I'm
a sucker for snow in games there there's
some hints that maybe this game you know
Assassin's Creed Rouge will be run again
rogue row right right right yeah so
we'll be tying into Assassin's Creed
United unity again you ready please
please Kevin but there are there there
are historical but you know in all
seriousness there are historical ties oh
yeah yeah between the two and it's gonna
be interesting because the french-indian
war the Seven Years War is you know part
of the background go leading into the
French Revolution sure it's part of what
caused the economic troubles for France
abscess or is what's going on unity my
concern is just the character himself
because so much of Assassin's Creed
hinges on like the general likability of
the main character then if he's just a
mega dick the whole time I don't know if
I'm gonna quite go for that but Tom's
not in the mega deck like so but you
know what I mean is Leslie's better than
Connor sure you know that's that's
that's really all I all I want is crazy
it's just better better than Connor so
you know what happens is every time
there's an assassin's creed that's
that's announced my tattoo actually
starts glowing and then there's like a
big assassin symbol in the sky kind of
like the dark mark so that's that's how
we all know to rally